I see the moon, and I know it sees me.
But do you know what some people see on the moon?
My mom says she sees a man on the moon.
My grandma sees a rabbit on the moon.
Ha ha, cute little bunny.
I even have a book about a kitty cat who thinks the moon is a bowl of milk.
My dad told me how some people throughout Asia have fun stories about the moon.
Some people think flowers fall from the moon when it is full.
Wow, I like that.
He said the flowers bring good luck.
But the most famous story is about the goddess of the moon...
...who magically flew to the moon and lived there in a jade palace.
My parents took me to the Harvest Moon Festival in San Francisco, California.
Some people think this is like a giant birthday party for the goddess.
There were all kinds of dancers.
Look at those pretty dresses.
The kung fu looked really cool.
I want to know how to do that, then I'd be awesome.
I even got to see the lion dancers.
It might look scary, but it's not.
See, there's a man underneath the costume holding up the head...
...making it look like the lion's mouth is opening and closing.
Then, other people hold up the rest of the costume to make up the lion's body.
They say the lion's visit gives us all good luck.
My favorite though, was the drummers.
Other than all of that fun stuff, I just like playing around.
Plus, did I mention the mooncakes?
Yum!
So, I had a lot of fun at the Harvest Moon Festival.
And now every time I see the moon, I think about how much fun it is...
...to have these special stories to share.